we are just a few hours away now from
president's arrival in las vegas he and
the first lady will be attending
saturday's memorial for senator harry
reid who passed away last week sasha
loftis joining us now from reid
international airport with when air
force one is set to arrive president
biden is set to arrive here in las vegas
in just a few hours ahead of harry
reid's funeral tomorrow at 11 a.m expect
some rolling traffic closures and delays
here at the airport as the president is
set to touch down air force one should
arrive at 7 25 tonight flying in from
colorado this will be president biden's
first visit to nevada as president he's
one of several prominent names speaking
at the memorial at the smith center
tomorrow others include speaker of the
house nancy pelosi senate majority
leader chuck schumer and former
president barack obama will deliver the
eulogy air force one will take off
tomorrow afternoon to leave las vegas
around 1 15 so expect those traffic and
momentary airport delays again now we
will be here at reed international
airport all evening tracking the
president's arrival so make sure to stay
with us both on air and online reporting
tonight at harry reid international
airport sasha loftis live local now